if somebody's going to try to Blackmail
me with advertising blackmail me with
money go yourself Elon Musk in his first
interview since publishing a post
agreeing with a user making an
anti-semitic comment earlier this month
on X apologized for what he called his
dumbest ever social media post but he
lashed out at advertisers leaving the
platform hope they stop you hope uh
don't advertise you don't want them to
advertise no what do you mean
if somebody's going to try to Blackmail
me with advertising blackmail me with
money go
yourself but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is well he didn't hold
back a slew of Brands including Disney
and apple decided to stop advertising on
the platform earlier this month this
after a report by liberal advocacy group
Media Matters said their ads were
appearing alongside pro-nazi content and
white nationalist posts earlier this
week musk visited Israel where he spoke
to families of Israeli hostages as well
met with prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu but he says the trip was not
an apology
tour